gene gene cheater video it's not a real
rejects month if there's not a gene
Jeter video ego loyal patronage AK gene
Jeter he has this video for us don't
know what it we're walking into if it's
one of his music ones if it's a short
film looks like there's an attractive
woman in the thumbnail wanted to happen
with gene the art tog refer of Julie fur
nice gene has on YouTube channel where
he does sketches short films trying not
to someone called trying to be
fascinated he's got a whole bunch of
content over there wonderful
photographer only photographs the best
of the best looking let's get into this
so Omar she has their cyber tutu or a
birthmark those petals
[Music]
[Music]
so much side of head and shoulder blade
okay this video some kids what I will go
down like why can't I
my own destiny on what I want to do I
did have my family and friends very
supportive to hell with them you guys
[Music]
over it's over
oh this profile is finished take it away
John haha I don't know I mean I guess it
was interesting to me to get a glimpse
into something that is very prevalent
now she brought up Instagram and I feel
like Instagram models get a bad rap or
at least or a go-to punching bag for all
sorts of ribs and jokes but I don't know
I think it's interesting to hear from
that perspective as to you know what she
gets out of it and why she chose to do
modeling why she chose to do more as she
described it provocative modeling that's
interesting to me because I feel like
there's a lot of looking at and
discussing from the outside and there's
not always a lot of perspective from the
inside so whether or not you know you
agree is one thing but I don't know I
thought is interesting to just get that
slice of life yeah it's fascinating to
hear about how
her family said that she should do
modeling then they encouraged her but
then when she went into the line of some
provocative modeling suddenly it was an
issue yes yeah they go to [ __ ] can't go
whoa whoa whoa we said modeling but
don't be sex oh don't be alright don't
be embracing I'm honest I mean it takes
a lot of confidence I think and all
jokes aside during the production I
think a lot of the time when you see
these like another thing I tend to like
make fun of is the commonality of
someone posing half-naked and then it's
followed with this like crazy personal
developing quote like that cliche is
something that just like this photo was
not the main thing that I think people
are getting from I'm pretty sure most
people are like damn she's good instead
of like oh wow some groomers I'm gonna
roll with that word of wisdom this quote
that they found somewhere and then paste
it at the top that's the main thing that
I will make make fun of but I do think
that there is a level of courage and
vulnerability and hard work it takes you
know especially for fitness models and
such and when you put your body on
display like that you open yourself up
to criticism immensely and so I think it
takes a lot of bravery actually to do
something like modeling it's something
that I think can make people very very
insecure and it's not just the people's
responses from like social media you
know times it could be the
photographer's you work with the
agencies the people who cast you for
these shoots who can be very judgmental
especially towards the woman in this
field so it is something that I agree we
tend to look from the outside and make
our criticisms about whether it be about
the the feel the line of work some
people chalk it up to oh it's just easy
you're just half-naked whatever wonders
or there is more to it than that
even I myself can be guilty of just
being like I wish I was just a hot girl
so like it's more than just being a hot
girl honestly well and there are I'm
sure a lot of downsides that you don't
see or just the inevitable things that
once you get a cool gig like that doing
something creative in a way
there are all these things that pop up
when you start doing something
consistently that are frustrating or
that are disheartening that you might
not even know about Yeahs especially in
the modeling field the whole point is to
you know be capturing some kind of
idyllic moment or creating some kind of
visual suggestion or narrative so it's
not all together always reality and I
think a lot of the time in this field
body-shaming is a very real thing and
what we each of us finds attractive is
different yes it's subjective it's like
some people try to strive for the
perfect body which is doesn't exist
because some people you know like does
she have a great body yeah but some
people might look at her and go too
skinny for me too thin and then they'll
they'll project that comment on saying
that but they'll protect that comment on
there and they'll they'll attack her
with their own subjectivity of what they
find attractive it's one thing to be
like that's person on my favorite kind
of body type but it's another thing to
attack on that one yeah because this is
weird thing where you have to expose
yourself and yet portray confidence like
what she's talking about here yet it
lends itself to so much insecurity yeah
yeah and I mean you know it's just funny
cuz it's like I I experience life very
differently because I'm a guy and so for
me it's interesting cuz I'm like I
wouldn't have the instinct to go on you
know line and post like a risque photo
so it's like it's all showed maybe I
will but it's yeah it's a perspective
that I don't get to tap into so I find
those kinds of things fascinating I am
not at all surprised sadly about you
knew it was coming the whole thing about
people hitting me up for free nudes and
sending dicks and stuff and feet pics
and all that like I got to imagine the
amount of weird that is she requests
you're exposed to it's probably pretty
high as well I mean we should probably
create some more clear-cut categories in
the public eye I think I personally have
no idea what her Instagram modeling
stuff looks like let's look it up she
can say provoke
modeling and then there's some types of
Instagram modeling where some people go
this sort of feels like it's actually
softcore porn so fine like really
establishing the lines because it's like
if a girl's Instagram page has millions
of followers and then most of it is her
half naked or showing her ass of the
camera it's safe to assume that a lot of
guys follow her so mainly Gawker right
and the category of what they're doing
is probably not pornography but a guy
can use it in a way for pornographic
purposes do you know what I mean
like they can sit there and touch
themselves to a photo even if their
intent with their modeling is not for
that so son but you can apply that to a
broad spectrum cuz like I mean you could
apply that to a bikini photo or
something like that oh yeah I mean I'm
saying half naked it's usually a bikini
or underwear you know well yeah and I am
saying that that's that's my point
though people will assume oh this you do
porn is this porn what she's doing and
I'm like well technically no even though
some people will say it is you know but
if she's not the first girl I've heard
Khmer have that complaint even if you're
not a model you Tod's are a girls are
gonna get hit up about stupid shows like
that if you're on social media and
you're attractive you're gonna get hit
up yeah yeah it's funny and it's hard to
establish the line I was just listening
to something and they hearkened to some
sort of court case that involved
pornography and whoever was leading the
proceedings basically said I can't
define it with words but I know it when
I see it and that's a tricky I feel like
there are certain things that are very
obviously porn but I feel like it's hard
to draw a very distinct line because at
a certain point things get blurry and
that's an interesting thing to me cuz I
wonder where that all comes from and I'm
sure part of it comes from just how we
deal with our sexuality as a society
exactly what I mean
yeah which is you know very I'm saying
the public we got to have a little bit
clearer definition sometimes well not
even a definition I feel like in the
public we need to have a better
understanding and a better cultural
awareness of sexuality and
general because overlapping what you're
saying in the mic yeah is it's okay keep
going it's that this is an ASMR video
everyone's gonna jack off to this it's
gonna be a porno of its very own no
nobody has made for adults what's also
demonetized is made for adults you know
YouTube's great yeah anyway this is fun
thank you guys for being here what's
your take on half the things we said I'm
sure all of us are in agreeance you can
follow Julie fir on Instagram it's at
the top of this Julie jeans well y-yes
with an underscore at the end of that on
Instagram go show your support and
followed Jeanne Jeter on YouTube he's a
great guy don't know what else to say
other than gene you're technically the
third member of the real rejects when
you think about it now we post so many
more short films now thanks to you the
fact that there's a gene video every
month shows you're the third member
congratulations yeah man don't ever
leave us know and do more videos like
this things yeah come take some photos
of us